yeah what hey I'm glad we got to work
and I got working okay so ah good i
started recording this is good so it so
it's a one-on-one interview with ola she
wrote to me ask him some questions i
said hey why don't we do a google plus
interview and we tried last week and had
technical difficulties we got it working
I don't want more of your questions now
so you're gonna have to laugh I can all
see them yeah they're almost this one
okay so let's go let's don't know what
you know what you are and you're in
canada on youth yeah I'm based in
Toronto on base in Toronto it's uh 250
p.m. right now here okay okay so people
for the people who are watching this who
are part of my audience you want to give
a quick intro as to what you're doing
and why we're talking I mean london UK
and i'm a company called Elim media my
sister or a marketing agency and we're
passionate about hugs i watched your
video about passion we're passionate
about hugs telling stories transforming
business and celebrating success and i
absolutely love your business model i
love the way that is constructed and you
send them documents at people they buy
things i did love everything capacity as
a businessman I fantastic and every time
I go onto your site i think this is such
a good model so you thought I've asked
you about about it and and whether or
not i had the right idea about it so you
know this is i've looked at it from this
side of the fence and i thought wow this
is the best sure how business model is
out there i'm really impressed so I
thought my questions were for you to
describe that how did you come up with
it and what are the three things that
make it successful and just couple more
so yeah I just this is just really me
excited about your business manag wow
okay how did I started I wish I could
say I had this big plan at the beginning
of how how this thing was gonna look uh
I'm not that smart you know that it
didn't start off with a big plan I i
sold my business i was in the venture
capital business afterwards and i
started my site just as a way to give
back I found that
one thing that really helped me with my
company was modeling success I looked
the famous entrepreneurs how they got
started and their stories inspired me
and change my business i was going for
making three hundred fifty dollars a
month and like not surviving to be able
to close nasa and johnson johnson as
customers and have people in in 30
countries buying my software and a lot
of that was due to the modeling success
modeling guys like Bill Gates and how
they got started and so I just wanted to
share that with people I felt like this
helped me so much and I didn't see
anything else online that was doing it
so I thought I'm just gonna make this
and I'm gonna share what helped me and
hopefully will help other people as well
and there was no real business model
behind it you love our business model I
didn't have a business model there was
nothing um it was just a desire to help
people and it started to take off and we
started getting traffic and people
started to write to me say hey Evan I
love your site can I contribute some
articles i'm a business coach I'm a
marketing expert and I thought hey why
not like it's extra by you for people
coming to my site and so we added those
into and then I discovered hey I might
be able to sell advertising like i got i
got people coming to my site um and it's
little from there once i realized that i
can make money from it then i worked on
adding more content at any more offers
you know getting more people to
contribute and blowing it up from there
but it really just started as a I don't
know if it's a hobby but just out of a
desire to help other entrepreneurs learn
from my mistakes because it's it's socks
and it's hard being an entrepreneur you
know getting my business off the ground
is is brutally tough and so I just
wanted to share what was helping for me
with other people and took off from
there mass exodus you know I think one
of the most encouraging things you can
hear from a successful person is them
admitting that it's tough can you meet
so many other people and for nosy just
oh noes up you know i'm just making
money overnight it was really easy i use
it it struck me you're thinking cuz
something must be wrong with you what am
i missing but to hear people's stories
is really encouraging so thank you for
that it was it was tough I
I turn down jobs out of university to
start this business with two partners
and and we thought we were smart you
know we thought we had a great product
and I had to say no to my friends who
wanted to go out for drinks and dinner
and I had to pick like which one thing I
could go to a month because I couldn't
afford it like I'm pulling out three
hundred dollars a month it wasn't enough
to survive and and it was so hard
because they were supposed to be jealous
of me right like I'm the entrepreneur
I'm chasing my dreams and and I was too
ashamed and scared I guess to tell them
hey guys no you're making your 80 ka
year as investment bankers but I can't
afford 20 bucks to come and have dinner
with you you know I was too embarrassed
to say that um it's it's rough it is
rough it really is rough and I totally
resonate with that whole need to look
successful because there is that in the
business world that if you don't look
successful in in some ways people were
looking in single if you can't help
yourself fair enough can you help me so
yeah it's good it's really nice of you
to be so honest that I love meeting
honest people who actually because when
you're struggling and you know everyone
else looks like they've been successful
you think you are so isolating you're so
alone and that whole title hungry
entrepreneurs need help like there's
milky like that all right one of them
chickens toy like The Hungry Caterpillar
I think that is so on point isn't it
what's your biggest pain that actually
I'm hungry you know the fridge and
there's no food in there cuz we couldn't
go shop in this month inna but I'm
sticking with this cuz I'm passionate
about and I actually think that
somewhere along the line it's gonna look
so thank you for just thank you for that
can ask you one next question yeah yeah
go for it which is um yeah what free
things do you think really changed it
for you you know so you either
struggling and you know it's not working
you've seen other people's what they're
doing but what would you say were the
three things that made because you said
there's not a model but maybe what
you're doing really successful if you if
you could list them yeah so the first
thing is
really doing something you're passionate
about huh like it's so hard running the
business that if you don't love what
you're doing you're gonna quit it's it's
just way too hard the only thing that
keeps it going is that you love what
you're doing like I started this
business helping entrepreneurs just
because i loved what i was doing i had
no money coming in from that business it
was really passion and if you look at
any famous successful entrepreneur who
they got started that was never to make
a ton of money yeah the money ends up
coming I don't say hey give all your
money away you want to make money but
it's not the primary purpose anal famous
entrepreneur will not tell you that I
started this business to make money they
started because they wanted to have an
impact or passion about something they
wanted to help people and the more you
help people the more you're gonna make
yes if you start a business just trying
to make money it's not gonna happen
you're probably gonna lose money start a
business around something you love doing
and you know helps people that's that's
like the most important rule nothing
else will help you nothing will save you
unless you love what you do because it's
so hard you gotta bust with brick walls
you have to take on part-time jobs just
to support what you're doing like you
got to love it that much or you're going
to quit so that's that's the most
important rule uh yes four three so
let's let's go to work I'm a tough
cookie I know it's good hey I like it
why not number 2 i'd say is model
success try not to have to come up with
every idea yourself right we beat
ourselves over the head trying to be a
genius and whatever goal you have
whatever problem you're facing now
someone has solved it before success
leaves clues you just have to follow
them and this is what this is what I
sucked within my first business I was
trying to come up with everything myself
until I hit rock bottom them and told my
partner like I'm quitting like this is
this is too much i can't handle this and
i realized hey I'm not the first guy to
try to do this before I was it was a
software company I'm not the first guy
to try to sell software before so i
looked at guys like microsoft from bill
gates and look at how mcafee got started
and into it got started and not how
gates make section million dollars now
like who can work how many billions but
021 like first idea little entrepreneur
to making that first million I wanted to
know that and those lessons help me
apply it to my business things I never
thought about before I put into my
business I made work for me and and I
felt so dumb like why does it have to
take this long and struggle for so much
and end a hit like this point where I
hated my life and hated everything about
my business before I realized oh there's
a way out um anyway model success
success leaves clues find someone who's
already done what you're trying to do
and put their strategies to watch for
you that's number two all right number
three I don't quit the dirty little
secret about entrepreneurship is we all
think about quitting our businesses
multiple times and we don't tell anybody
right when you meet people itself oh
yeah it's great I you know I just landed
this flying things are going really well
not like oh my gosh things suck I'm not
making any money this is way too much
work for what I'm doing I'm gonna I'm
gonna quit and go back and get a job
because at least like we all think about
that and you can't quit like you have to
keep going i member um i was on a phone
call with my business partner in the
software company and and i just had
enough like 300 bucks a month and not
surviving you can only do that for so
long if you can really live off the
energy and momentum for so long before
like reality hits you in the face and
you got to do something and i told them
one night I've never been on my parents
house and family dinner I forget what it
was and I went upstairs talking partner
and said like I quit like this is enough
I can't do this out I'm struggling so
much i'm not happy i hate everything
about my life i can't i gotta go do
something else and then I hung up the
phone and I cried for like half an hour
and my mom came up and put her hand on
my shoulder and I couldn't even talk to
her for like the next 15 minutes because
i was just so overwhelmed ah and i went
to bed that night barely slept
but you know i got up next an impact
that work like you gotta keep going no
it sucks you but you have to keep going
you got to find something in you that
you keep going and what helped me was
first the stories of famous
entrepreneurs and we realized that that
people like Bill Gates and Milton
Hershey and whoever you want to look at
they all struggled it wasn't easy for
them they all struggle till it's not an
overnight success story not feeling like
like I'm a stupid guy who can't make
this thing work it just takes time and
you got to keep at it there's that it
and also I didn't wanna I didn't want to
live a life of regret yeah we want to
look back and say you know what if I
woke up that Monday morning and I gave
it my all and didn't throw it in you
know I didn't want to think about the
the the other side where I thought you
know I have an excuse never won have an
excuse for not saying he I gave that my
best yeah which bezos found of Amazon
when he started it he was uh he was 40
years old around there he was a
youngest-ever vice president and an
aggressive Bank company and he left it
all to start a dot-com company and at
that time com was nothing like when
Amazon got started people thought it was
crazy Jack and crate what are you doing
you're leaving your that you're the
youngest ever VP at this company why are
you throwing your life away to start
this Compeyson who's gonna buy books
online that's a stupid idea and he said
you know what I gotta try this because
otherwise I'm gonna let the rest of my
life and your gret for not having done
and so that's what happens if you quit
like I reminded myself of that if I quit
now i'm gonna kick myself i'm gonna be
so upset in in a couple years when i'm
looking at like I'm doing this crappy
job I'm not realizing my potential i'm
working with a boss that I hate young
Bruce Lee ninety percent of america and
in England you know gets up to a job
that they hate yeah right and so that's
your life if you don't make this
business work that's what you're going
back to and so you have to constantly
remind yourself of that rock with you
know like you're going to have crappy
days
but you got to get up next day and go
again yeah there you go follow your
passion model success don't quit my
three rules yes so on track so
definitely modeling you so I'll call you
in two years time so yeah whatever I'm
not you it does happen to take two years
either right come on absolutely it
doesn't but I just thought that would be
a nice time anyway my next question yeah
it's about business hogs so we talk
about something called a business hug
which is right here in understanding and
giving back incredible value so then our
relationship economy unless you hug your
customers you're gonna leave you for
somewhere else there's a lot question to
you is how do you hug your customers
that's a great question and I think you
have to hug more than just your
customers you hugged everybody in your
network um on my customers I try to
provide just as much support as I can
you know most of my customers now if I
look at who my customers are they're
entrepreneurs but most of them they
can't afford my services hmm you know
entrepreneurs are broke why not you guys
don't have money they're trying to make
money and that's good you know get your
hustle on that's great um I try to reach
out and just support people as much as I
can um I found what really helps is I
used to do everything by email so people
wouldn't ask a question and respond to
them now I try to make it into a video
because it can help more people yeah you
know people write to me and ask me a
question and I'll say hey that's an
awesome question i'll make a video
response for you and I post it on
youtube so it helps them but it also
helps everybody else who has the same
question yes so like you asked me to do
an interview and I said hey great like I
can answer I you know but how about we
do a video and other people have the
same questions that you have will
benefit from it and so just trying to
it's the same amount of time for me to
write or to speak but you have a greater
impact and again would expand this
beyond my nap but you want my customers
to everybody in your network like if you
want to get referrals i like i like your
hug that's good I might I might credit
you and you said but you gotta hug
everybody in your network
absolutely you want people to refer you
business you can't just sit back in your
chair I wait for people to give you
business right you have to stay top of
mind you should be out there giving
referrals to the your colleagues and
helping them with their business and
giving them ideas to grow I had a
newsletter reader right in the other day
saying she wanted help with her social
media plan I want to training and I have
a worksheet that I sell and I said here
this is a great worksheet seven bucks
you can you can use it but if you want
like intense training I don't do that
but I have a friend of mine who does and
i made a video i called him up live on
my video and I said hey sean is Hema
Sean laughs at hey Sean I gotta leave
for you before you say anything you're
on video so don't say nothing we're
gonna regret and so I told me about the
lead like he's he's ecstatic and give
him a chance to talk about his business
as well and then I connected them so
like what's going on here this woman
writes in I can't help her but I give
her someone who can so she's in my
network Sean's on my network and I've
just passed him a lead you know it's up
to him to close it but I passed him some
business and I've given him some video
exposure on my site on youtube and also
no hay in this video to Shawn Moffitt is
getting plug everywhere well and
everybody watches that video also gets
benefit too so it's like sending out
massive karma hugs everywhere across
your network and that comes back so
hugging your customers is great like
that that gets them telling more clients
about you get some repeat business gets
them buying more from you increasing
their budgets with you and you hug your
network and they're gonna give you leads
and it's funny like you help people like
this is way more fun than me answering
these questions on email right I get to
know you a little bit better and it's a
lot more fun when you're hugging your
network absolutely it's really good we
are we we've designated the 28th of
November as business hub day the day and
businesses hug my customers however bad
it says i have my customers i'm going to
email it to you i have work us to
another video on that what november 2828
forever okay let's do it let's set up a
time with what day is that it's a
thursday
yeah I do my hippos I do these on
Thursdays absolutely look off that time
and let's have another chat at the end
of november and we'll talk about hug day
Oh excellent Priam your huggable
business definitely a burster so they
lost my last question I mean yes copper
or you lunch actually because it's lunch
time there is near suppertime here and
but so if you're looking at the social
media landscape but no you said you
don't do so she made a bit looking at
landscape and how businesses are
becoming more and more engaging social
media a lot more things are being
transacted online where do you see
yourself in five years oh wow that's a
battement yeah hey don't do social media
I do a lot of social media I don't know
maybe I don't know I must make it was
really tired or something like that oh
that's tough you know what I'm always
looking for ways to better support my
audience uh-huh it's that when i first
started with social media i looked at
twitter and thought it was stupid like
why people talk about their chats and
what they for dinner and all that stuff
and then i did a search for my name my
website and i found that the people were
talking about me and it was all good
which was good it's not like oh that
Evan he's a loser don't talk to him it
was all good stuff and you want to be a
part of the conversation at least a bare
minimum for just getting started in
social media recognize your champions
the people who are talking about you
just say hey thanks and you'll do it
again over and over again links is also
unsolicited they were talking about me
and so I joined the conversation slowly
eventually became a thought leader and
adding my own content YouTube's and
tweets and Facebook and all that but it
can be scary you know they get started
as an entrepreneur social media we have
so many things to do already it's like
here's another thing that you need to do
for your business right like shoot me
now I'd want things to worry about so
definitely go into it slowly I did and I
found that my customers were there and
we got bleep that's like the best part
of my day now the best part of these on
beyond like talking to you guys and
doing the videos is every morning I wake
up and I look at the comments on my
youtube videos and and they're almost
all good
and people have awesome things to say
and that makes my day like well I made
that video and it changed that person's
life and so I'm eating my lentils for
breakfast first yeah lent lentils and a
hotdog cut up into it you gotta get some
high protein there that's like walking
every day and I load my youtube comments
and I start replying the people and that
makes me it makes my day it sets me up
awesomely for the day and I wasn't doing
anything on YouTube a while ago so it's
crazy how quickly your your life and
your schedule can change based on where
you're getting results don't go crazy on
social media if you're not seen any
results like are your customers there
are they talking about it can you join
the conversation I don't know where it's
going to be in five years I know I'm
doing a lot more videos now I went from
doing like one a month maybe I know it
there was maybe a year and a half or
didn't do anything now i'm launching 14
videos a week yeah that's crazy it was
like youtube has changed our motto and
more like it's a great way to connect
with people it's a lot of fun yeah we
like youtube in the fact is so easy now
especially that what Google Hangouts you
need to put up this is I'll of google
this is must be the best thing they've
invented well let's pull video up like
that so yeah and that tell you agree
with your social media it's nice to
connect with people and be genuine and
then to hear then come back to you with
that kind of comments and nice weeks to
say you imagine waking up every morning
and people have got nice things to say
about you had cool is that it's right
yeah I mean that's the ultimate
motivator for me and it's also using
your hug analogy it's a great way to hug
the people in your network like somebody
tweets out your post or says thank you
you give them a hug huh but you give him
a hug like even if it's just a smiley
face yeah or thank you like that makes a
difference that person just got hug they
got recognized it doesn't take a lot of
work to reach out and thank the people
in your network no absolutely like well
I'm gonna say a very very big [ __ ] thank
you and a big hug
pick up to you everyone for talking to
me and taking time out I really do
appreciate it it's just so nice and yes
I am I have you in my book of heroes
look at zeros alright cool hey listen
it's been great for my audience if they
want to learn more about you what's
what's the pitch and like where's the
website they can go to so our website is
um WWE lemme do not spend because we've
got to e so it's a ela NM e di a.com
yeah and we're a marketing agencies we
do social media marketing for
entrepreneurs we help businesses hug
their customers and become huggable so
they stand out from their competition so
their customers buy them because they're
huggable as opposed to choose on price
so we teach you to be a huggable
business build your mocking muscles and
hug your customers tightly I like it I
like well thanks for the time and hey if
you want a book that November 28 hug day
I'll with you absolutely thank you i
enjoy your dinner way did you enjoy
today at the sunshine but whatever is
doing character right now thanks haha